Arozabillahi mina Shaytan Rajim Bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim Allahumma Salla Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin Wa Ala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin Wa Barikwa Sallam Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa Yassir Li Amri Wahlul Uqdatam illisani Yafkahu Qawli Asalam Alaikum wa Rahmatullahi Wabarakatu
In the previous session, we talked about the concepts of transcendence and imminence of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So we learnt that in one way, Allah is immensely distant out of His loftiness and because of His magnificence.
But then at the same time, He is extremely close to our hearts and our consciousness.
as the Quran says that he's closer to us than our jugular vein and what that basically means is our consciousness because when you cut the jugular vein the first thing that you lose is your consciousness.
So in one instance he is extremely distant from us and in another he is extremely close and there's this beautiful
verse in Urdu, which I really like that I think that describes his imminence and his transcendence in a really beautiful way in which the poet says, Ke duri ki yahad hai, ki tasavur bi khata hai.
And what the poet is saying there is that Allah is so transcendent, He is so distant from us that even imagining anything about Him is a sin.
But on the other hand, He is so close to us that He is closer to me than my jugular vein.
And I think that is a really beautiful way in which the poet expresses this concept of transcendence and imminence.
We also looked at the distinction between Allah and his attributes and we saw that how he is incompatible by both of these so Lay said commitly he shy and the word commitly he it's actually a combination of ka and Mithli he one used for attributes the other used for essence and the verse reveals to us that he is incompatible through attributes as well as through essence
so now that we've covered this noun Allah and his adjectives ar-Rahman ar-Raheem today I want to talk about Issam right because it starts with ismillah ar-Rahman ar-Raheem the Alif is dropped because of a grammatical rule which I'll talk about later but that the ba is actually joined with the Issam and the word Issam in Arabic it means two things it means a noun you know as in the grammatical term noun
but and it also means name because every noun has a name so the classical Arabs they just used it interchangeably now from a Quranic perspective this concept of name is extremely important because it is the names the Asma that elevated Adam over the angels
and made him worthy of their prostration.
Also because these names were something that were directly taught to Adam by none other than Allah himself.
So, Allah taught Adam all the names.
So the concept of name is actually extremely important in the human psyche because we are Bani Adam, we are the children of Adam.
Now, what is the name?
A name is basically the ability of symbolic thought.
That is the essence of a name.
So naming something is taking a symbol, which is linguistic in nature, and then applying that symbol to something which is either material or empirical, conceptual or even theoretical, right?
Those are all entities that are actually named.
We give a name to them.
Or a name can be something that can be used as a means of abstraction in order to create separation in things.
So you can have a broad category called cars and then you can further break them down, further abstract each one of them by giving them additional names, right?
Mercedes, Toyota, BMW, Audi, all of these.
So now this is something that only we can do.
Animals cannot do this.
Animals cannot use symbolic language.
This is something that only human beings are capable of.
It has been agreed by the Arab scholars that human beings have basically three dominant modes of symbolic language.
We have linguistics, which is the highest form, and then we have mathematics, which believe it or not, actually comes under linguistics.
This has always been the mindset of the ancient people.
It's only the 20th century and the Western civilization that elevated mathematics over language.
Today, language has taken a secondary place, and that is because people don't understand the power of language, especially the Arabic language.
and this is why even Muslims today they try to place mathematics over the linguistics of Quran when they want to try to prove it as a miracle and you know no doubt Quran is mathematically perfect I'm not you know discrediting that and actually I've shown you a lot of examples of that in the sessions on is Quran a miracle but the fact of the matter is that what makes Quran a miracle is not its mathematical perfection but rather its linguistic perfection
and this is something that as Muslims we really need to understand and appreciate and you know this need to prove Quran mathematically it actually comes from this feeling of inferiority before the god of modern science which of course there is mathematics you know this comes from Newton and Einstein and all these other people who elevated mathematics and said that it is the only real way of understanding reality
right and the reason they say that is because mathematics is precise and it is exact but then these people did not study classical Arabic because Arabic is precise and Arabic is exact in fact it is precise and exact to a degree that mathematics cannot even come close to and this is why the miracle of Quran the Ajaz of Quran is not in its mathematics it is in its linguistic perfection and eloquence
So Quran is a linguistic medical.
But the recognition of this, this concept of recognizing the fact that Quran is a linguistic medical, it actually comes from our ability to recognize things through names.
Because names have meanings, right?
They help us identify, they help us recognize things.
So the actual power of recognizing the Quran
as a linguistic medical it comes through our ability of understanding names and this is why ism is so important to understand this concept of ism and when it comes to classical Arabic even the letters become prominent even the sounds become prominent in fact you know if you take the Arabic language so when I say a tree for example in English right
you see something that has a trunk that has branches and and leaves you know that's what comes to your mind when I say the word tree right it if it's a pomade it has a trunk and then it has these palm fibers or you know if it's a fir tree then it's got all these spikes instead of leaves but but basically there are three types of trees right you have the fir trees you have the pomades and then you have these with leaves so when we say shajar in Arabic
What is the difference between a shajar and a tree?
I mean, we could argue that they're completely arbitrary, right?
And this is a dominant opinion among most linguists in most languages that names really have no connection to the thing that is named other than the fact that they are basically signs that human beings have collectively agreed upon.
So their opinion is that the Arabs saw the structure of a trunk with the branches and leaves and they decided to call it shajar, whereas in English they decided to call it a tree.
But the ancient Arab would actually completely disagree with that.
They would argue that there is a deep relationship between the word shajar and this thing out there that we see.
Because Shajar is made-up of three letters.
This word, this name, Shajar, is made-up of three letters, Sheen, Jeem, and Ara.
Now, whenever you have the letter Sheen, this is called Harfattafashi in Arabic.
The letter Sheen is always used for something that spreads out, that has radiation, like Shams, the sun.
Shar, hair, hair has radiation because it spreads out, it's all spread all over the body.
Shajar has radiation because a tree has these branches that spread out.
So Sheen is a very specific word and it has a very specific meaning.
Then there is the letter Jeen which is Harfu Shidda, right?
It's a strong letter.
It is used to represent things that are strong in their nature because
The basis of a tree is strength.
It is strong.
It's the trunk, right?
That's why it has the letter Jin.
**** the body, the main structure of the human being, strength.
Jabal, a mountain, starts with the letter Jin because it's powerful by its very nature, right?
So Jin is Harfu Shidda.
Then there is the letter Ara.
which is the letter of repetition trees are constantly regenerating themselves they're repeating themselves so the ancient Arab would argue that there's a deep relationship between the letters and the things that named itself and this is something I mean these are philosophical debates about the nature of language but the Arabs would definitely say that there is a secret in names you know
In classical Arabic names are not arbitrary.
There is actually a very good reason why a shajar is called a shajar and a shams is called a shams with those particular sounds in those particular order.
And this is why we know that these sounds, they have an effect.
The sounds of the Arabic letters have an effect on the human consciousness.
There is no denying that.
The recitation of Quran has a powerful effect on human consciousness, just by the very nature of it sounds.
So even if you don't understand a single word, just listening to a good recitation can deeply move your heart.
and if you look up on the internet you'll find so many examples of people converting to Islam simply after hearing a recitation or hearing the other or something like that because these sounds they you know they're not arbitrary they have a very deep effect on the human consciousness so Arabic is an incredible miraculous language in every way shape or form and it's very different from other languages of the world
But what I'm trying, the reason I'm explaining all this to you is because I want you to understand that all of its power, the power of this Arabic language, it actually boils down to the human ability to understand names.
You know, these asma that are provided for us within the framework of language.
So
it's it's no coincidence that Allah started the statement with Bismillahirahmanirahim and it actually you'll see what I'll explain as we go along you'll see the power of what that statement means now we understand the meaning of names right so let's talk about the purpose of language what is the purpose of language the purpose of language generally is communication right we want to be able to deliver communication express ourselves but
If you actually analyze the purpose of language itself, it actually is unification.
Language unifies.
This is the secret of the human being, that we have this ability to abstract, differentiate, and identify things uniquely through names.
We as human beings, we have this ability to see the one in the many.
That's the only way we can communicate.
I mean, this is really profound.
Think about it.
The only way we can communicate is by seeing the one in the many.
What am I talking about?
So for example, if we talk about a lecture, let's say, right?
So for example, I tell you that there's going to be a session next Sunday at 9:30 a.m.
How do you know what the word session means in that context?
How do you know what that statement means?
The word session in that context, because the word session has many different meanings in different contexts.
So, I could say, you know, I'm recording a religious session, or the school is in session, right?
The courtroom is in session.
Yasmin had a great tennis coaching session the Federal Act was passed in the session of 1908 so the word session can have so many different meanings in different context so but when I say there's going to be a session tomorrow how do you know which meaning of the word session I'm talking about
The only way you know that is because you are extracting that one particular meaning of that word within that context out of so many other possibilities.
And this is something we all do instinctively all the time.
This is just an ability that we human beings have because we have this inherent capability to extract the one out of the many.
And when we're not able to do that,
When we're not able to zero in on one particular meaning, we are then forced to ask, wait a minute, I just want to make sure, did you mean this or did you mean that?
Why do we do that?
Because we're trying to find that one particular meaning.
You see that?
So every sentence, every phrase, every word, it needs to boil down to one particular thought from a sea of possibilities.
And so what language and in particular names or these nouns, what they enable us to do is they enable us to speak intelligently about the oneness and the unified nature of words.
Because that is who we are.
We are all unifiers by our very inherent nature.
This is what we as human beings were created to do.
We are muwahidun by our natures.
We were designed to make one out of many through language.
This is why Adam was given the gift of names, this gift of language because using names we can unify.
Language is a sign of Allah within our existence, within the human existence that that is what you have been created to do.
to perform the ultimate unification, tawheed, because that's what the word unification means in Arabic, tawheed.
We were created for tawheed, to single out the one ilah, the one true Allah from all these possibilities and all these deities in our life posing as false gods.
SubhanAllah.
So you can see how profound this concept of name or Isim becomes.
So now that you understand that, the next question is where does the process of this recognition of Allah begin?
It begins with Ismullah.
It begins with the name of Allah.
Now the word Isim linguistically it comes from two root words.
It comes from Samu
and it comes from wasama okay the word isim it actually comes from samu or wasama the word samu it means lofty something very high like the sky in Arabic is called a sama right and the word wasama it actually means a sign or a symbol
Alright so isim is basically a combination of two things it is samu and wasama so it is basically a sign for those it's a lofty sign for those who can see so if you break this word down isim linguistically it actually means a lofty sign coming from samu and wasama a lofty sign that's what isim is it's an alama
It's something you put onto something in order to signify it.
So it's essentially a signifier that indicates the signified.
Right?
So Islam is a lofty sign.
In fact, in Surah Tur-Rum, Allah says, From His signs, the creations of the heavens and the earth.
And in the variance
your tongues and your colors so Allah relates the tongues to the heavens right because you have you have the heavens first and then the earth and he says and then he says you know in the variance of your tongues and your skin color so he relates tongues to the heavens and he relates the skin color to the earth
and this is called Tabaq in Arabic which is this concept it's a type of antithesis where you use opposites to explain something so he talks about heaven and earth and then he relates them to tongues and colors like you know our skin color and our speech so there is a relationship between tongues and heaven and there is a relationship between skin color and the earth because speech comes from heaven you see speech
Allah taught human beings or He taught Adam or rather He imprinted within Adam language.
Allama means to imprint, right?
The Rahman imprinted within the human being the Quran.
That's literally what Allama means to imprint something.
Language was imprinted within the human being.
And this is why all human beings have this common ability to learn languages.
Now complexions is something that comes from the earth because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said that Adam was created from all the topsoil of the earth, right?
From the white, the black, the brown, the yellow, the red.
So you get all these variances in human complexions because Adam was created from Udma.
You see the word Udma in Arabic, it means topsoil.
And Adam means the one who was created from topsoil.
So all human beings have these different complexions just as there are all these colors of the soil.
You have white soil and then you have pure white, right?
You have red soil, yellow soil.
black and then ebony black.
So complexions are related to the earth and language or speech is related to the heaven.
Language is meaning, complexion is sensory.
You see?
There's a relationship between meaning and sensory.
They're both joined in the human being.
So what is significant and what is palpable?
what we understand and what we can see, touch and feel.
So the sensory and the meaning are gathered in these two phenomena, the phenomena of language and the body.
Because the essence of human being is language.
We are defined as al-haywan and nathik, the speaking or the articulating animal.
Because what is the essence of language?
It is rationality, right?
Language is meaningful.
So the essence of the human being is language.
And that's why, you know, when we judge a person by their skin color, it is just so wrong because you're judging them by something that is just incidental to their nature, right?
But when you judge somebody by what they believe in,
by how they speak, by what they say, by whether they're truthful or not, whether they're virtuous or not, whether they stand for the truth or not.
I mean, that's how human beings should be judged.
That's why Dr.
King, he talked about being judged by the content of character.
In one of his speech, he said that we should judge people by the content of character.
And how do you know the content of character?
By the essence of that person.
And what is the essence?
their belief because that's what's going to manifest from them so judging somebody by the skin color is just wrong at so many levels anyway so Isim means a lofty or a heavenly sign now the statement of Bismillah begins with the Isim of Allah the lofty signs pointing to Allah
because that is the only way we can know Allah through the power of symbolic understanding, right?
We cannot know Allah as we know things.
We cannot know Allah the same way we know an MP3 player or a laptop or a computer because, you know, essences are hard to understand even with things, but when it comes to Allah, it's absolutely impossible.
So the only way we can know Allah is through symbolic language, which are these symbols within language and these symbols within existence, which he calls his ayat, right?
So he has his ayat within language, which is in the form of Quran, and then he has his ayats, his lofty symbols within existence in the form of the heavens and the earth, and everything in between.
So now I'm bringing this entire concept all together, right?
So you understand this idea of unification accomplished through language, and these signs, because if you look at the signs, there are numerous signs.
There is a whole ocean, this vast ocean of signs around us, but they all condense down to one particular, they're all pointing to one particular entity, which is Allah.
Right?
So, that's what we find in the horizon.
We will keep showing them our signs, our numerous signs within the horizons and within their soul,
until it becomes absolutely clear to them that this is all coming from Al-Haqq from the one truth one reality which is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala but and if you look at the Quran it directs us to his 99 divine names right as familiar linguistic symbols so that we can gain some concept of who he is
That's why he uses these familiar names.
So for instance, Allah says he is Malik-e-Aumidin, right?
He is the owner or the king of the day of judgment.
How are we able to understand that?
How do we understand what that means?
We only understand that because we understand the concept of Malik, right?
We understand the concept of a king.
And this enables us to relate to and appreciate the position that Allah will take on the day of judgment.
He will assume the position of a king or the ultimate owner.
But if you really think about it we are only able to understand that because of the symbolic reference.
But then we also learn that Allah is not limited to our concept of what a king means.
He's way more exalted than that.
right so he's we get an idea that he's a king but then we also understand that it's not like the kingship that we know of but at least that concept of king it gives us some understanding of his position and his relationship with us right it just at the very least it gets the point across so there is a distinction between Allah and the name of Allah there's a distinction between Issam and Allah the Issam
are all these lofty signs and symbols that He created for us in the horizons and within our souls in various numerous dimensions.
They enable us to know Him.
That's an Ism.
That is what Ismullah means.
A lofty heavenly sign or a symbol that helps us recognize Allah.
You see?
because I recognize you by your name you recognize me by my name so name is what helps us recognize so now that we understand the linguistic meaning of the word isim as a lofty heavenly sign what we can now appreciate about bismillahirrahmanirrahim is you know now I'm talking in the linguistic sense that what we understand from it now is
the lofty signs in the heavens and the earth and everywhere around us pointing to Allah and helping us recognize Him as Ar-Rahman and Raheem.
Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Raheem with the lofty heavenly signs that Allah has created for me in order for them to help me recognize that He is Ar-Rahman ar-Raheem, the intensely merciful and the consistently merciful.
InshaAllah in the next session we will look at this preposition Ba that is joined with the Issan and we will explore the depth of this entire phrase and we will see the power behind reciting Bismillah Rahman Raheem and you will see how perfectly this statement serves as the crown of Surah Al-Fateha right it's sitting on on top of Surah Al-Fateha like a crown because it really it really deserves that Maqam
Alhamdulillahi Abil Alameen wassalatu wassalam ala rasuli saydam Muhammadin Khatibin Nabiin wassaydin Musaleen walahi wa wassi alibnabi Talib ashrafil wassiyin wa alal aimmatimin zuriatima taibinatahirin wassalam alaihi majmain alfatia